[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und bettina schausten guten abend
auf seinem ersten besuch im nahen osten
ist der amerikanische präsident joe
biden am frühen abend in saudi arabien
gelandet per direktflug kam er aus tel
aviv ist keinesfalls selbstverständlich
ist wie fast nichts im nahen osten
und so bleibt auch dieser besuch eine
schwierige mission den saudischen
kronprinzen dem die ermordung des
journalisten kvb angelastet wird nannte
biden einen schoppen und verhandelt nun
doch mit den saudis über öl und andere
enttäuschung hinterließ sein abstecher
heute früh in die palästinensergebiete
damit beginnt michael bewerunge sein
bericht
ein handschlag wie unter alten freunden
und doch mehr die erneuerung einer
freundschaft durch joe biden nach dem
seinen vorgängern donald trump die
verbindungen zu palästinenserpräsident
abbas weitgehend gekappt hatte ebenso
wie einen großteil der us hilfsgelder
für die palästinenser biden hat neue
dollar zu sagen in dreistelliger
millionenhöhe mitgebracht politische
initiativen fehlanzeige was man seinem
bekenntnis zur zwei-staaten-lösung zu
halten ist räumt er selbst ein
auch wenn im moment der boden nicht
bereitet ist um wieder mit verhandlungen
zu beginnen werden die usa und meine
regierung nicht aufgeben zu versuchen
palästinenser und israelis enger
zusammenzubringen
das klingt wie zweckoptimismus und kann
abas nicht zufriedenstellen der hätte
sich konkrete schritte wie die
wiedereröffnung des von trump
geschlossenen us konsulats in
ost-jerusalem gewünscht auf druck
israels hatten die usa den plan fallen
gelassen
der schlüssel zu frieden und sicherheit
beginnt mit der anerkennung des staates
palästina und damit dass das
palästinensische volk seine legitimen
rechte
doch daran glaubt auf den straßen von
bethlehem kaum jemand mehr das interesse
an beiden besuch hält sich in grenzen
die wenigen zuschauer vor ort sind
gekommen um zu protestieren
heute ist ein schwarzer tag beiden kommt
und liefert uns den juden aus und wir
empfangen und feiern ihn noch nie doch
am nachmittag joe biden den kleinen
nahostkonflikt schon hinter sich
gelassen und wendet sich dem größeren zu
der neuordnung der
sicherheitsarchitektur des gesamten
mittleren ostens nichts könnte das
symbolischer verdeutlichen als seinen
flug von israel nach saudi arabien
der erste offizielle direktflug in der
geschichte der beiden länder nach
jahrzehnten feindschaft hat auch israel
nun volle überflugrechte eine
atemberaubende annäherung der gemeinsame
gegner iran macht sie möglich breiten
wir die atomare bewaffnung des irans
notfalls mit gewalt verhindern nach der
landung in jeddah wird er versuchen die
saudis noch stärker in die anti iran
koalition israels mit vielen anderen
arabischen staaten zu integrieren kein
leichtes unterfangen
saudi arabien ist einer der pfeiler in
einer solchen situation die ist wie ein
puzzle zu dem jeder staat etwas
beitragen sollte aber ohne frage wäre
dieses puzzle viel besser mit saudi
arabien als ohne
als ob das nicht kompliziert genug wäre
heisst der starke mann der saudis auch
noch mohammad bin salman der kronprinz
der mutmaßlich den journalisten kvg
ermorden ließ beiden hat ihn öffentlich
als paria bezeichnet und muss jetzt doch
die neue ordnung mit ihm verhandeln
ja unser us korrespondent mrt wissen
begleitet die reise des präsidenten und
ist uns jetzt aussteller zugeschaltet ja
wir haben es gehört immer ein paria
staat hat beiden saudi arabien schon
mehrfach genannt was treibt ihn dorthin
zu fahren ist geht um eine neue ordnung
geht es auch um öl für die usa
ja es geht auch um öl aber nicht allein
für die usa sondern im grunde genommen
für die ganze welt in dieser
energiekrise auch am ende für
deutschland und joe biden ist vor
wenigen minuten hier vor die presse
getreten in jeddah konnte aber nichts
kräht vorweisen zu der frage ob es
tatsächlich ein massive ausdehnung der
ölförderung geben soll darüber wird man
morgen im golf rat noch mal intensiv
beraten aber er ist zuversichtlich dass
man in vielen punkten einigkeit
erreichen kann er hat einige vorhin
genannt und das wichtigste ist
sicherlich er will eine allianz
schmieden zwischen israel und den
arabischen staaten gegen den iran als
den großen gegner in der region und
gleichzeitig eben auch dafür sorgen dass
der einfluss chinas in dieser region der
ist nämlich groß und der wächst ständig
weiter dass dieser einfluss
zurückgedrängt wird joe biden hat auch
versprochen das thema menschenrechte
anzusprechen in saudi arabien aber das
saudische königshaus kann ja sein besuch
doch mit großer genugtuung vermarkten
dieses bild geht jetzt um die welt
begrüßung durch den kronprinzen wie viel
glaubwürdigkeit kostet beiden dieses
bild
kostet eine menge glaubwürdigkeit gerade
in der kurzen pressekonferenz ist er
massiv unter druck geraten wegen der
fragen eben genau danach wie kann es
sein dass er sich mit mohammed bin
salman hier trifft und geschäfte machen
will aber joe biden versucht
gleichzeitig auch ein stück weit zu
erklären warum das so ist das weiße haus
hat in den vergangenen monaten darum
gerungen ob man sich hier mit bin salman
treffen sollen und ist am ende zu dem
schluss gekommen man kommt um ihn nicht
herum ist der künftige herrscher saudi
arabiens und ohne ihn wird es keine
saudi arabische und israelische
freundschaft geben die länger hält ohne
ihn wird es eben auch keine front
gegenüber dem iran geben und auch kein
zurückdrängen des einflusses von china
und deshalb redet er mit ihm aber er
müsste natürlich auch massiv die
menschen und bürgerrechte verletzungen
hier ansprechen und damit sehen wir ein
thema das wir derzeit ja auch im
verhältnis des westens zu russland zu
china diskutieren was leitet die
aussenpolitik moral oder wirtschaftliche
interessen des eine schwierige abwägung
auch bei diesem besuch
absolutes zeigt im grunde genommen es
gibt kein schwarz weiß es gibt
eigentlich nur grautöne und da ist ein
bündnis mit saudi arabien vielleicht das
kleinere übel wenn man sieht dass china
und russland den autoritarismus eben
weiter ausdehnen wollen übrigens auch
hier in der region in den letzten
monaten sind von fünf golfstaaten
hochrangige delegation nach china
gereist sie wollen unterstützung bei der
infrastruktur bei technologie eigentlich
würden sie das lieber mit den
amerikanern machen und sie auch als
militärische schutzmacht hier haben
unterläge dann für die usa natürlich die
große chance denn wenn sie das tun und
das wollen sie dann hätten sie auch
einen hebel in der hand konkrete zusagen
einzufordern was bürger und
menschenrechte angeht tut beiden das
nicht dann hat seine außenpolitik jede
glaubwürdigkeit verloren mrt wissen in
jeddah ganz vielen dank
ins inland und da ist der sommer auch
nicht mehr das was er mal war die
deutsche sehnsucht nach unbeschwerten
urlaub im süden wird in diesem jahr jäh
ausgebremst von ausgefallenen
ferienfliegern von hitzewellen und
bränden und schließlich auch noch von
corona die sommer welle rollt und
vermied so manchem den erhofften summer
of freedom der gesundheitsminister am
gerät deshalb heute auch jüngeren unter
60 sich eine vierte impfung zu holen das
versprechen noch am ehesten ein sommer
ohne risiko bisher sehen empfehlungen
von eu und stiko das nicht vor und so
sorgt karl lauterbach vor allem für eins
verwirrung aus berlin 27
selten hat die angst vor dem winter die
politik des sommers so sehr bestimmt wie
in diesem jahr wie deutschland durch die
kalte jahreszeit kommt darum geht es
nicht nur beim gas darum geht es auch
bei der pandemie eine vierte impfung
auch für jüngere für menschen unter 60
das ist ein lösungsvorschlag des
gesundheitsministers um zumindest die
aktuelle welle noch vor dem herbst zu
brechen
das kann sehr sinnvoll sein weil dann
ist das risiko sich zu infizieren
zunächst einmal reduziert und wenn man
sich infiziert ist das longo witt risiko
wahrscheinlich auch niedriger
lauterbachs vorschlag ist nicht neu doch
die frage nach der vierten impfung
erhält gerade neue dringlichkeit die
sommer welle dieses jahres ist ohne
beispiel die inzidenz hoch die
dunkelziffer wohl ebenso das nährt die
sorge vor einem noch schlimmeren herbst
wir haben auf den intensivstationen
stand heute 1218 patienten das sind
nochmal gut 100 mehr als vor einer woche
auch drei mal so viel wie vor einem jahr
und fünf mal so viel viel vor zwei
jahren im sommer also eine angespannte
situation
drei viertel der aktuellen corona
intensivpatienten sind über 60 auch
deshalb ist die impfung für jüngere
umstritten die eigentlich zuständige
ständige impfkommission widerspricht dem
gesundheitsminister deutlich es gebe
keine daten die lauterbacher ratschlag
rechtfertigten sagte stiko chef thomas
mertens ich halte es für schlecht
medizinische empfehlungen unter dem
motto viel hilft viel auszusprechen
seine kommission empfiehlt nur über
70-jährige und risikogruppen das vierte
mal zu impfen und bleibt dabei doch
lauterbach wir von einem konflikt nichts
wissen
die co-chef merkens hat darauf
hingewiesen dass es bei den unter
60-jährigen keine studien gibt die da
zum beispiel eine bessere sterblichkeit
zeugen würden das bestreitet niemand das
ist ja so aber es hat sich für alle
altersgruppen auch bei den unter 60
jährigen gezeigt ist man zum vierten mal
geimpft dann infiziert man sich nicht so
schnell das timing des
gesundheitsministers verwundert
zumindest auf den ersten blick denn
eigentlich verspricht sein ministerium
für september neue an virusvarianten
angepasste impfstoffe auf den zweiten
blick wird deutlich dieser zeitplan
wackelt das problem mit den angepassten
impfstoffen ist dass wir zum einen noch
nicht genau wissen wann sie kommen zum
zweiten sind sie auf die ursprüngliche
omikron variante angepasst das heißt auf
ba1 und nicht auf der 5 was ja jetzt
inzwischen zirkuliert die angst vor dem
winter sie produziert im moment mehr
fragen als antworten
jetzt weitere wichtige nachrichten des
tages grunde lag auf
der bundeswehroffizier frank o a ist zu
einer haftstrafe von fünf jahren und
sechs monaten verurteilt worden das
oberlandesgericht frankfurt am main
sprach in der vorbereitung einer
schweren staatsgefährdenden straftat
schuldig der terrorverdacht sei
begründet zugrunde liege eine
rechtsextremistische gesinnung der
33-jährige habe anschläge auf politiker
und prominente geplant monatelang hatte
er sich als syrische flüchtlinge
ausgegeben und ein doppelleben geführt
die verteidigung kündigte revision an
wegen mutmaßlich rechtsextremistischer
chats einer gruppe von polizisten sind
in münster straf und
disziplinarverfahren eingeleitet worden
sieben aktive und ein ehemaliges
mitglied von sek spezialeinheiten sollen
bilder und videos mit extremistischen
inhalten ausgetauscht haben nordrhein
westfalens innenminister räumte als
oberster dienstherr null toleranz gelte
hier ausdrücklich auch nach innen
bundesarbeits und sozialminister heil
will wegen der enormen preissteigerungen
im kommenden jahr die hartz 4 sätze
erhöhen zudem dürften entlastungen wegen
der hohen inflation nur menschen mit
kleinen und mittleren einkommen zu
kommen sagte der spd politiker dem
redaktions netzwerk deutschland
unterstützung kommt von gewerkschaften
sozialverbänden und aus den reihen der
grünen
widerspruch von der fdp
die russische führung hat gesetze
verabschieden lassen die die umstellung
der russischen wirtschaft auf den kriegs
bedarf begleiten
zudem wurden in moskau weitere
sondersitzungen des russischen
parlaments angekündigt unterschiedliche
angaben nicht überprüfbar gibt es zu dem
russischen beschuss der ukrainischen
stadt wie nie zu laut russischen
verteidigungsministerium ist ein
militärisches ziel getroffen worden nach
ukrainischen angaben wurden zivile
einrichtungen angegriffen die zahl der
todesopfer ist auf 23 gestiegen
die republik moldau nachbarland der
ukraine trägt schwer an den folgen des
krieges
hunderttausende flüchtlinge nahm das
arme land auf um dies abzumildern will
die internationale gemeinschaft die
republik moldau mit 600 millionen euro
unterstützen außenministerin baerbock
sagte als co-vorsitzende einer
geberkonferenz im rumänischen bukarest
77 millionen euro als deutschen beitrag
zu das geld soll in die flüchtlingshilfe
gehen und auch die extrem hohen
energiepreise abfedern
ein jahr nach der flut wir haben gestern
über den jahrestag in den
katastrophengebieten in rheinland-pfalz
und nordrhein-westfalen
berichtet auch in stolberg bei aachen
standen am 15 juli letzten jahres viele
vor den trümmern ihrer existenz auch
viele firmen wie das
traditionsunternehmen prim
druckknöpfe sind die spezialität und die
qualität ist weltbekannt doch das letzte
jahr hat der firma noch mal alles
abverlangt es war ein harter kampf zeigt
ralph goldmann
die produktion läuft wieder zu fast 100
prozent hier werden druckknöpfe
beispielsweise für baby- strampler
hergestellt bei der firma prim in
stolberg bei aachen
betriebsleiter axel wirth müller hatte
die hoffnung nie aufgegeben ich habe mir
mal fest fangen geglaubt dass ich
irgendwann mal wiederherstellung wird
das ganze wieder so in betrieb nehmen
können
aber es war es war an dem tag
unvorstellbar was da eigentlich passiert
ist um dort keiner mit gerechnet
dieser tag vor einem jahr an dem der
kleine fluss ficht das ganze unternehmen
flutete die spende des nachbar betriebs
wurden in den keller gespült in der
nacht brachte die feuerwehr die
belegschaft aus der firma axel wirth
müller gab sich schon damals kämpferisch
auf jeden fall ist der wille nicht nur
von der geschäftsführung auch von der
familie da ganz klar hier wieder weiter
zu machen hier wieder aufzubauen und das
versuchen wir jetzt mit vereinten
kräften
prim scheint die krise als chance
genutzt zu haben das unternehmen gilt
als sogenannter störfall betrieb weil
sie hier auch chemikalien lagern beim
wiederaufbau mussten sie bestimmte
auflagen erfüllen der keller erstrahlt
jetzt in neuem glanz die fenster zur
straße wurden zugemauert und es gibt
überall hochwasserschutz die kosten etwa
20 millionen euro für wiederaufbau und
produktionsausfall übernimmt die
versicherung
ich kenne unternehmen die nicht
versichert waren ich kenne auch
unternehmen auch zahlreiche
privatpersonen muss nicht ganz so gut
läuft
wir können da wirklich froh sein dass
wir einen
versicherungspartner haben der das im
großen und ganzen sehr gut mit uns
entwickelt die industrie und
handelskammer unterstützt die firmen bei
den hilfs anträgen alleine im westen
nordrhein westfalens waren und sind 2500
unternehmen von der flut betroffen große
industriebetriebe mittelständler und
einzelhandel einige mussten aufgeben
krone und die flut das war zu viel
andere sind auch vom boden verschwunden
wir wissen gar nicht wo sie sind wir
haben sie mehrfach angeschrieben auch
das ist ein stück dieses dramas aber wie
gesagt diese fälle sind jetzt soweit
verdaut und wir gucken jetzt nach vorne
und helfen all denjenigen die anpacken
und wieder aufbauen in der stollberger
fußgängerzonen sind sie von normalität
allerdings noch weit entfernt kaum ein
geschäft hat bisher den neustart
geschafft die stadt muss sich komplett
neu erfinden das traditionsunternehmen
prim scheint es geschafft zu haben mit
durchhaltevermögen viel solidarität und
einer versicherung die auch zahlt andere
hatten dieses glück nicht und es könnte
noch jahre dauern bis die folgen der
flutkatastrophe in den unternehmen
bewältigt sind
und jetzt noch einmal nachrichten gute
nase
die eu-kommission hat mehrere verfahren
gegen das mitgliedsland ungarn
eingeleitet mit einer klage beim
europäischen gerichtshof soll das
regierungskritische club radio seine
sendelizenz wieder erhalten eine weitere
klage richtet sich gegen den
diskriminierenden umgang mit
homosexuellen in ungarn vor dem
hintergrund mehrerer krisen schauen die
finanzmärkte zu diesem wochenschluss auf
neue wirtschaftsdaten aus china dort
legte das wachstum im zweiten quartal im
vergleich zum vorjahr kaum zu valerie
haller wenn chinas wirtschaft schwächelt
hat das enorme folgen auch für
deutschland ja denn die volksrepublik
ist ja der mit abstand wichtigste
handelspartner für deutschland dass die
wachstumsmaschine nun ins stottern gerät
ist also keine gute nachricht für die
exportnation deutschland
grund für die konjunkturschwäche ist
chinas 0-coup politik doch peking hält
unbeirrt daran fest bei kleinsten
ausbrüchen werden ganze stadtviertel
abgeriegelt fabriken und geschäfte
müssten dichtmachen
in den häfen stauen sich die container
die folge lieferschwierigkeiten und
materialengpässe all das hat seinen
preis im zweiten quartal ist die
chinesische wirtschaft im vergleich zum
vorjahr um magere 0,4 prozent gewachsen
ein harter einbruch im ersten quartal
hatte sie noch um 4,8 prozent zugelegt
das schwache wachstum enthält sozialen
sprengstoff die arbeitslosigkeit wächst
gleichzeitig kämpft das land mit einer
immobilienkrise die zusehends auf
kleinere banken über greift immer wieder
demonstrieren verzweifelte chinesen wir
hier vor ein paar tagen in der
millionenstadt schenken hunderttausende
bankkunden kommen seit monaten nicht
mehr an ihr geld die stimmung im land
angespannt peking versucht
dagegenzuhalten mit viel geld für die
infrastruktur um die konjunktur
anzukurbeln dabei sind sich viele
experten einig das effektivste
konjunkturprogramm wäre eine abkehr von
0 coup doch damit rechnet in china kaum
jemand und man bleibt bei der harten
linie danke ballerina frankfurt
der süden europas leidet weiterhin unter
extremer hitze und trockenheit an der
französischen atlantikküste kämpfen
derzeit rund 1000 feuerwehrleute gegen
ungewöhnlich starke waldbrände und 7000
hektar land sind laut örtlichen behörden
bereits verwüstet mehr als 10.000
menschen mussten in sicherheit gebracht
werden darunter deutsche touristen
temperaturen von bis zu 40 grad und
winde erschweren die löscharbeiten und
die hitze belastet auch die radsportler
bei der tour de france bei 35 grad
südlich von lyon ging die dreizehnte
etappe mit einem weiteren erfolg für
dänemark zu enden mats persson sicherte
sich nach rund 190 kilometern im sprint
den tages landsmann dinge guard konnte
sein gelbes trikot verteidigen und der
berliner simon geschke zum vierten mal
das bergtrikot schon jetzt ein deutscher
rekord
es sind 70 steilen stufen hoch zum
erfurter mariendom und severikirche
eine einmalige architektur und wie
gemacht als große bühne die
domstufen-festspiele erfurt beginnen
heute abend nach zweijähriger corona
pause und es wird spektakulär verdis
oper in der die israeliten ihre freiheit
erkämpfen gegen den babylonischen könig
bekommt in diesem jahr ungeahnte
aktualität
nabucco
dies erster großer erfolg und es wird
auch einer in erfurt werden davon ist
dann jeder sonntag überzeugt
er hält sich für den größten den einzig
wahren herrscher die geschichte des
königs nabucco der die juden unter
werfende stammt aus dem alten testament
verdis erste erfolgsoper gerade jetzt
aktueller denn je die erfurter
inszenierung zieht deutliche vergleichen
es gibt extrem große parallel in der
aggressions wut der beiden figuren das
heißt sie sagen quasi das gleiche ich
werde sie für nicht nur durch seine euch
alle vernichten und ich bin nur das
richtige und wenn man ein bisschen
anvisiert alles was wir lesen die letzte
zeiten dann sind die parallele schon da
parallelen und inspiration in untersagen
die menschen den berühmten
gefangenenchor aus nabucco als
freiheitshymne in erfurt war die musik
in den ukrainischen national frau
für sängerin valerie amos diese oper
auch eine rettung sie ist aus der
ukraine geflüchtet und bekam die rolle
der fina nabucco tochter die sich gegen
die vernichtung auflehnt
kunst und wirklichkeit
michael perels lab in meine eltern
wohnen in nikolajew heute fielen mehr
als zehn bomben eine ganz in der nähe
der wohnung meiner mutter
janis jetzt verstehe ich diese oper
besser es ist mir wirklich näher ich
verstehe wie wertvoll menschliches leben
ist und wie wichtig der kampf um die
eigene freiheit und man gewinnt immer
auch für die zuschauer der generalprobe
kam die botschaft
der aktuelle bezug zur ukraine war schön
super eindrucksvoll kostüme
und auch einfach eine spannende
handlungen so die aktualität dieser ist
durch die zeit immer fortgeführt hat es
auf recht beeindruckend
nabucco erhebt sich selbst zum gott und
wird darüber wahnsinnig bei verdi bereut
der despot aber mit großer geste
da kommt man natürlich an begriffe wie
toleranz die akzeptanz wie großzügigkeit
wie seine eigene schule zu erkennen und
auch sich
konvertieren und das tut alles nabucco
das ist richtig die frage ob es das
zulässt
[Musik]
keine gnade für den diktator nabucco
noch bis zum siebten august auf den
erfurter domstufen
na dann nichts wie nach erfolg der
freiheitskampf bietet die brücke zum
politbarometer
eine große mehrheit der deutschen ist
für die weitere unterstützung der
ukraine unabhängig von steigenden
energiepreisen die details hat jetzt
matthias fornoff
guten abend willkommen zum
politbarometer
dreht russland uns den gashahn zu bis
zum 21 juli dauern die wartungsarbeiten
an der gaspipeline nord stream 1 wird
danach wieder gas fließen eine knappe
mehrheit der befragten ist da
optimistisch fast genauso viele
bezweifeln dass russland weiter liefert
im andauernden krieg sollte der westen
die ukraine stärker als bisher
militärisch unterstützen das findet etwa
jeder dritte deutlich weniger als vor
zwei wochen
eine konsequenz des krieges spüren wir
schon jetzt die energiepreise steigen
rasant
70 prozent finden wir sollten die
ukraine weiterhin unterstützen auch wenn
das bei uns mit höheren energiepreisen
verbunden ist 22 prozent wollen das
nicht
mehrheiten dafür finden sich bei allen
parteianhängern außer bei denen der afd
die meisten deutschen sind also bereit
einschränkungen hinzunehmen um der
ukraine zu helfen
doch sie erwarten dafür deutlich mehr
unterstützung gut drei viertel finden
die maßnahmen der bundesregierung zur
entlastung der bürger reichen nicht aus
der krieg in der ukraine steigende
preise ein drohender gas mangel im
winter wachsende corona zahlen vielen
menschen sind verunsicherungen und
sorgen zurzeit groß die zufriedenheit
mit der regierung und der politik
insgesamt sinkt in der top ten der
wichtigsten politikerinnen und politiker
verlieren fast alle deutlich an
zustimmung auf der skala von plus 5 bis
minus 5 bewertet nach sympathie und
leistung steht sarah wagenknecht auf dem
letzten platz - 0,6 leicht verbessert
friedrich merz minus 0,4 schlechter
platz 8 christian lindner minus 0,1 mit
den größten verlusten
davor markus söder minus 0,1 platz sechs
karl lauterbach 0,4 cem özdemir 0,8 alle
drei mit verlusten olaf scholz rutscht
ab auf platz vier 0,8 deutlich
schlechter der dritte platz für hubertus
heil 0,9 auch eher schlechter platz zwei
für annalena baerbock 1,2 und ganz vorne
robert habeck 1,6 beide deutlich
schlechter
die führenden politiker aller parteien
erhalten also schlechte noten zur
unzufriedenheit hat sich ja auch die
event hochzeit des finanzministers mit
promis und politprominenz auf sylt
beigetragen während viele bürger den
gürtel enger schnallen sollen
in deutschland gehe es eher ungerecht zu
sagen dann auch knapp zwei drittel der
befragten deutlich mehr als noch vor gut
einem jahr
wenn am sonntag bundestagswahl wäre käme
die spd unverändert auf 21 prozent
cdu/csu auf 26 prozent minus 1 die
grünen erreichten 25 die fdp 6 prozent
beide unverändert
die afg 11 plus 1 die linke 5 prozent
unverändert
man mag es ja kaum noch hören aber
corona ist noch nicht vorbei die
infektionszahlen steigen corona bedingt
fällt in vielen bereichen das personal
aus in einigen kliniken müssen schon
wieder verschoben werden und die zahl
derer die um ihre gesundheit fürchten
die steigt eine mehrheit hält die
aktuelle corona lage für problematisch
oder sogar sehr problematisch
gleichzeitig aber gelten derzeit so gut
wie keine einschränkungen
51 prozent finden das gut 47 prozent
finden das nicht gut in dieser gruppe
sind die anhänger von afg und fdp am
wenigsten vertreten
wenn die temperaturen sinken und die
zahlen weiter steigen droht uns wohl ein
erneuter corona herbst mit
einschränkungen und als wäre das nicht
genug dazu womöglich noch eine kalte
wohnung die bundesregierung sucht nach
auswegen und will zumindest
übergangsweise weiter auf
kohlekraftwerke setzen obwohl die
klimaschädlich sind
das finden 68 prozent gut 28 prozent
schlecht selbst bei anhängern der grünen
findet sich für diese maßnahme noch eine
mehrheit der ukraine krieg und die
folgen für unsere energiesicherheit
lassen uns manche überzeugungen über
bord werfen dabei zählen umwelt und
energie wende für die befragten nach wie
vor zu den wichtigsten problemen in
deutschland
für zwei drittel der befragten sind
hitze und dürre in diesem sommer direkte
folgen des klimawandels 30 prozent
halten die temperaturen für normale
wetterschwankungen
sommerliche ferienstimmung und sorgen
wegen krieg corona und energieknappheit
liegen nahe beieinander
das haben die zahlen dieses
politbarometers deutlich gezeigt
das war unser bericht über die stimmung
im land die grafiken und alle
informationen zu unseren umfragen finden
sie wie immer im zdf text ab seite 165
in der zdf- heute- app und oft zdf
heute.de wie die repräsentativen
umfragen der forschungsgruppe wahlen
zustande kommen informationen zur
methodik und zu den qualitätsstandards
finden sie unter politbarometer punkt
zdf.de
vielen dank für ihr interesse das
nächste politbarometer gibt es dann am
12 august nach dem wetter folgt hier
gleich der zdf comedy sommer ihnen einen
entspannten abend auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend ein kleines tief zieht heran
und mit seiner kaltfront regt es
tatsächlich mal bei uns vor allen dingen
dämpft dieses tief aber die temperaturen
an der küste dann kommt das nächste hoch
jürgen heißt das und dann wird's heiß
oder nacht fällt an der nordsee erst mal
regen und in der zweiten nachthälfte
zieht der regen weiter nach osten da
kann auch mal ein kleines gewitter dabei
sein südlich der nördlichen
mittelgebirge bleibt es trocken die
temperaturen sinken auf 14 bis 6 grad
und am kältesten wird hier der oberpfalz
morgen liegen die höchsttemperaturen an
der see bei 17 bis 20 grad sonst werden
20 bis 24 und hier in teilen von bayern
baden-württemberg in hessen rheinland
pfalz und dem saarland sommerliche 25
bis 29 grad erreicht morgen vormittag
kann es im osten noch letzte
regenschauer und gewitter geben die dann
aber rasch nach osten abziehen bei einem
recht kräftigen wind aus nordwestlichen
richtungen sonst ist es mal mehr mal
weniger stark bewölkt und am sonnigsten
wirtz zwischen dem oberrhein und dem
karwendel am sonntag jetzt in
süddeutschland mehr sonne bei 26 bis 32
grad im norden dominieren die wolken bei
19 bis 26 grad und dann wird es heiß am
montag steigen die temperaturen schon
bis 36 grad und am dienstag werden hier
im west- bis zu 41 grad erreicht das ist
eine sehr trockene hitze wie sie aber
hier am trend für trier sehen können
geht es danach deutlich weniger heiß
weiter schönes wochenende